this is kami a red ruffed lemur  her world is small and it's shrinking  daily  the red ruffed lemur comes by its name  honestly  it's covered in a brilliant chestnut  coat  the rest of its body its face hands  belly and tail are a deep black  of the hundreds of species of lima in  madagascar the red ruffed lemur is one  of the most endangered found only on a  single peninsula in the northwest of the  island country the rainforest the red  raft lima coal home are also highly  valued for the beautiful rosewood and  ebony trees that grow there  it's in the canopy of these trees that  you can find these lemurs  there they search for fruit which makes  up nearly their whole diet  their home forests are being harvested  at an alarming rate  taking the red rough lemur's chance of  survival with them  conservationists estimate that there are  only three to five thousand left in the  wild  this is the red raft lemur  you